foreign
experiences I've ever had this guy
that doesn't know me was the reason that
that I'm no longer an agent
what is the state of morale of the CVP
right now it's not existent I just been
that way for a while we're losing about
50 of our applicants just in the
polygraph phase
most other agencies will see they lose
about a third of their applicants we
lose 50 percent we used to lose
two-thirds of our applicants so for us
it's a matter of we're losing a lot of
really great people because of this
polygraph portion
um and there's really we're stuck with
it because the law requires that new
agents go through a polymer
unfortunately they're not being
administered properly everyone's being
treated like they're a criminal and
unfortunately we're losing a lot of
people including those who have private
military service uh who have active
security clearances and then they fail a
CBP polygraph it doesn't make any sense
I entered on duty with U.S border Patrol
on January 12 2004. it was just
something that always intrigued me my
husband and I we were we're both agents
my twins were born uh January 17th of
2014. you know having twins it was just
something that you know it's just it's
crazy I worked you know just strictly
day shift and he would work swing shift
meaning that he would go in at four
o'clock so we were literally like two
ships passing in the night one of the
days my my husband was driving home from
work and uh he fell asleep and he
totaled our vehicle luckily he was okay
but this was like not even five miles
out of out of hebronville where we
worked and just out of sheer exhaustion
you know we were we were barely making
it and so after that I was like you know
what you know something has to give so
it was either going to be you know my
career or my family and so you know I
chose to essentially give up my career
after all of this my husband ended up uh
having a major uh accident he uh tore
both his quad tendons his quadricep
tendons he he couldn't perform the
duties of a border patrol agent anymore
I started the process of going back to
work when I first joined the patrol back
in 2004 uh polygraphs were not part of
our of our hiring process so
um they said the only thing that they
told me was that in order for me to go
back then I would have to undergo a
polygraph I was like well I mean that's
fine I don't
not not a big deal so I thought
[Applause]
[Music]
I actually did two polygraphs but
because my first one was inconclusive
that was what uh what they told me so my
second one was done about a month and a
half later and that one was in a police
station and that one was literally like
um an in an interrogation room to me it
already felt like you know like I was
like a criminal or something he started
accusing me of all kinds of things he
asked me about my my background my
family life and I told him I had four
kids and the twins and you know it was
crazy and and he's like oh so do you uh
use your husband's prescription
medication with wine to take the edge
off and I was like no I was like what I
was like what gives you that impression
he also accused me of skimming which was
something that I had never heard that
you know taking taking uh drugs from
drug bust that we had you know that I
was skimming from from those busts and
and taking stuff for myself he told me
that um he's like he's like you failed
and you feel bad he's like like serial
killer bad
and I was like what and you know and he
was like yeah he's like you're he's like
you're lying about everything and I was
like what are you talking about I was
like no I'm not I've been a law
enforcement officer for you know almost
my entire adult life you know I was like
there's nothing that I've done I was
like I've always held myself to a higher
standard it was a horrible horrible
experience I you know with it I just I
never anticipated something like that
these people who literally sit with you
for you know two hours in this guy's
case like an hour and a half is he he
was literally the end-all to my career
you know to to me coming back to
something that you know that I was good
at law enforcement in general it's been
hard to recoup people 13 000 or so
employees are very retired that's
throughout all of CBP that's Customs
officers border patrol agents and other
Personnel in the agency so we're at a
point now where uh that's five it's only
five years from now we have to replace
them somehow but if we can't even meet
our yearly hiring goals we still don't
set a chance of being able to replace
all those people
they'll go to other agencies DPS here in
Texas they uh they pick up a lot of
people who don't get hired by CBP uh
they'll go to any other police
department it's uh they'll go any other
place where they're not treated like a
criminal during that portion of the
hiring process
and one of the crazy things is I still
hold a uh a clearance and I actually
work as a background investigator under
contract with CBP those same people who
you know are trying to get hired by CVP
uh you know I I conduct their background
investigation so I'm good enough to do
that but I'm not good enough to you know
to be a border patrol agent it just it
doesn't make any sense
thank you